well governor sislak is calling nevada's
economy
the hardest hit due to the kopit-19
pandemic but
in his state of the state address
earlier tonight he says he does have a
plan to get the state
back on the right track eight news now
reporter orco omana explains
we have so much to fix but we are
forging
a new path forward governor steve
sissellac state of the state address
centering around the coven 19 pandemic
and its devastating effect on nevada's
economy his recovery plan focusing on
renewable energy
to generate billions of dollars and
thousands of jobs he's also calling for
the creation of innovation zones
to allow new companies to come to nevada
and there's a focus on preparing our
workforce for these emerging industries
i will be calling on some of nevada's
leading companies to fund
design and implement training programs
to prepare and qualify employees
for these jobs governor sisalak also
hopes to fast track capital improvement
projects and he wants upgrades made at
dieter following its many issues dealing
with record unemployment
our computer infrastructure is still
outdated and our systems can be improved
governor sisilak says the plan will
create 30 000 short-term jobs and over
165
thousand permanent jobs
[Music]
nevada's number one priority right now
is continuing the covet 19 vaccine
rollout to date over 100 thousand doses
have been administered but more are
needed from the federal government
we must continue wearing masks washing
hands and social distancing
and when your turn comes everyone must
get the vaccine
the governor also reiterating his
position on education
i will do whatever it takes to get our
students back in the classroom
a lot of what happens next depends on
the state's budget the governor wants to
add 50 million dollars to help small
businesses and he says nearly one in
four nevadans are on medicaid
another result of massive job losses
despite the challenges governor sisilak
is hopeful
the state of our state is determined
resilient
and strong orco mana 8 news now
assembly republican leader robin titus
offered the republican response to the
governor state of the state she
criticized the state's covid response
and also spoke of a lack of resources in
our overall state health care system
assemblywoman titus also spoke on how
the pandemic
runs much deeper than just covet our
health care crisis goes beyond
the pandemic itself opioid abuse and
mental health problems continue to
devastate the lives of many nevadans
we can't ignore these issues but we also
shouldn't exacerbate the problem
through restrictive policies dr titus
also discussed education and how remote
learning should only be a short-term
option and spoke of how the state should
focus on continuing to create jobs as
nevadans attempt to recover
from the first mandatory shutdown you
can watch the full response from dr
titus over on our website
eightnewsnow.com